hey hey let's go on a real hunt it's
been a while since we've gotten a new
Assassin's Creed game and Ubisoft
promises origins to be a fresh take on
the franchise while origin still has
some things you'd expect from an AC game
here are some of the biggest changes
while you will still be assassinating
countless people Assassin's Creed origin
serves as a good jumping on point for
new players it takes place in Egypt well
before the first game and features a
fresh new cast of characters you play as
by Ekta last Magi as Cleopatra is
overthrowing your brother and ascending
the throne while you'll find references
to previous games new players should
have no trouble following the story this
time around say goodbye to the mini-map
and hello to the compass on the top of
your screen you'll find a Skyrim like
compass that's populated with question
marks and other points of interest this
may seem like a small change but it
feeds into a stronger sense of
exploration rather than constantly
pulling up your map or checking the
mini-map to reach your destination
just follow the objective marker on the
compass now you can admire the beautiful
views of Egypt and follow your intuition
in the seamless world
[Music]
the combat in Origins has gone through
an overhaul the free-flowing combat of
previous games has been replaced with a
Dark Souls esque hitbox style detection
combat this means you'll need to read
your opponent's time your dodges and get
behind your enemies to deliver powerful
blows while you could use different
weapons in previous Assassin's Creed
games origins boasts a wide range of
different weapon types that all play and
feel different axes are slower but pack
a punch while dual swords force byuk to
get in close with speedy hacks and
slashes origins plays more like an
action RPG than its predecessors this
means that as you kill enemies complete
quests and find new locations you will
gain experience and level up weapons
will have a level requirement and quest
in regions will have a suggested level
although nothing is really stopping you
from checking out a high level area or
tackling a quest that might be a little
too hard for byuk loot goes hand in hand
with most RPGs and origins is no
different there are three tiers of
rarity regular rare and legendary or
blue purple and yellow for the most part
you get weapons randomly but certain
quests will net you legendary weapons
with special perks pretty much
everything you equip will have a rarity
tier however costumes do not affect your
stats no matter the rarity thanks for
watching and if you want to know we
thought of assassin's creed origins be
sure to check out our review on GameSpot
calm
[Applause]
why is this gladiator running in circles
you